[Music]  for years Taylor Swift was arguably the  queen of independence day known for  throwing epic celebrity-filled bashes by  the beach I just have a great time with  these things you know but this year the  28 year old singer opted for something  different spending the holiday with her  man Joe always  [Music]  check out the couple making a rare  public outing together in Turks and  Caicos Taylor all cuddled up with Joe  during a relaxing dip in the ocean the  blonde beauty showed off her patriotism  rocking a cute red white and blue  striped swimsuit something we hope never  goes out of style  Taylor's passion for celebrating America  Swifties are now speculating if this  marked the end of Taylor seaside soirees  seeing as it's the second year in a row  she skipped it  [Music]  whether it's a fireworks fiesta or just  chillin with Joe Taylor will always be  the queen a fourth of July to us  [Music]  you  [Music]